freshly minted hall-of-famer from the
Bears Brian Urlacher joining us joining
us on behalf of FanDuel which includes
challenging fans to various contests
during the NFL season we'll get to that
coming up in a moment
Urlacher or lacquer does it matter I say
Urlacher my family the Urlacher side
says Urlacher wait your family even
screws it up I believe it's a locker
that's what I'm gonna believe it's your
locker
what they say it is it is all my uncle's
and Locker side say your locker but then
oh my god Chicago was Urlacher you I
don't I'm not gonna correct you when you
say or locker or locker but it it rhymes
with linebacker it does that's what the
is it's not linebacker yeah it could be
it's good to see ya we were wondering if
my Ford annette's jumped you right now
in a real fight
so they jumped on you yeah so let's say
you walk down an alley here in New York
yeah and you got those four girls nine
yeah just then nope no weapons no
weapons just them we're gonna have a
good one do you think you could take it
I mean yeah I think I could I mean it's
gonna be good but they may know what
what they're UFC guys or something no
they're not cuz you can see guys like
there's normal guys but they're UFC
fighters different story but they're not
I can get them have you ever run into
somebody who wants a piece of you oh no
I'll probably no nobody ever says all
you don't look that tough everyone's
like I thought you'd be a lot bigger
important Thanks what do you weigh now
250 245 oh my god okay and you played at
55 okay just lost a few pounds yeah my
weight fluctuates so I'll wake up at
2:40 to go to bed at 250 and goes wake
up at 243 it's really weird my weight
fluctuates like 810 pounds a day I think
it must be water weight like I'm a boxer
or something but do you ever want to hit
somebody no tackle hunch anything no
just tackle no I do not you don't miss
that I don't miss that part no I don't
miss my body being sore I don't miss
sitting in meetings for four hours a day
I don't miss I'm saying that stuff yeah
I would think that you'd still that want
that feel just like what's the perfect
tackle feel
good it's just you know because
sometimes you hit a guy and you can't
you kind of film wiggle and there's
times when you hit guys you're like
there's no movement at all on either
side that's how you like my finesse
that's how you know without head I asked
Ray Lewis about this a couple of weeks
ago when I saw him I said you and Brian
tackled correctly but right you wouldn't
I don't know if you'd have to change it
now right
well so how many times in the game do
you have a perfect tackle not very not
many you really practice those perfect
tackles all the time and you never get a
minute but you didn't launch no we
didn't like you guys wrapped up yeah you
wrap up well it's you know it's a lost
art it really is you know now that it's
did you which I agree with get your head
up and see what you hit but he's in the
NDI get the guy on the ground I don't
care how you tackle him you got to get
him on the ground and with the rules
today if you're thinking about where
you're gonna put your helmet or where
you're gonna hit a guy you probably miss
the tackle and that's what it's come to
these days is just there's too much
thinking involved in the tackle you ever
knock yourself out hitting somebody I
got knocked out I knock myself out 2003
were playing at Denver and Clinton poor
I'm we're playing horses are running
back and I'm coming off a block and I
spin and I hit him and we both fall down
and I fall asleep before I hit the
ground I miss to place Matt now again
two weeks a month or whatever well back
then it was two plays and go back in but
what do you remember when you went to
the sidelines like how do you get back
into the game
the train was like hey you okay I'm
pretty good there but uh because it
happens so average your medical
clearance yeah I was like dang Tim what
happened oh you got knocked out so you
got his name right yeah I feel good
remember this I'm like okay you asked me
later I you know back in that's it now
it's just so much different but you
wouldn't change your tackling no right
now no it's like no my approach even in
today's even no I feel like I might
attacks will still be legal you know
there's I think it finds sometimes for
how much a helmet and all that stuff but
that's just gonna happen being
aggressive I wonder how this is gonna be
called I wonder if we start out and
we're really strict and then we ease up
sir like pass interference was yeah I
don't makes the most sense
why can't you review this penalty you
know College rejects five guys a game
for the for the targeting rule
why can't the NFL go back and not eject
guys I think it's silly to eject guys in
college as well well why can't they
review these penalties they're big
points in games you look 15 yards is a
big deal to a defense in a football game
or offense however you look at it why
can't you go back and review these
things they review every damn thing in a
game but I can't you review that I do
I'm waiting for a rule to come in that
helps the defense me too they've taken
away everything I just wish they would
let the guys you know on college you can
and there was the corners can bump and
run the whole way downfield unless the
balls in the air I wish you'd do that
the NFL's well the five-yard rule is I
think handcuffed the defense the most
because their corners got you know five
yards is not that far and same way with
the tight ends and the safeties guarding
them it's just hard man the Bears
getting clonic yes so excited how good
was that that's a steal to first your
own pigs no problem yeah you can have
them because you don't know if those
pigs are gonna pay off for you in the
first place and now you're getting a guy
who's an all-pro with two positions that
outside backer and a defensive end in
the same year Defensive Player of the
Year
sign me up and then you paid him which I
understand I heard you talking to Nate
how they didn't pay him in Oakland or I
don't know they could I don't know what
Jon Gruden is doing it almost feels like
he's saying I got this grace period in
Oakland I'm gonna build this team up and
be ready to go in Las Vegas that makes
sense they have more you know they don't
pay one guy frees up more money for
other guys you can pay and you got more
picks down the line from the baby you're
paying car now to be great he's your
quarterback I know but I'm saying and
that's why the Bears can afford to do
this with Mack because the money is not
invested in the quarterback yet you know
it down his line hopefully they will be
in Mitch but I'm so ecstatic that they
got him
I was already excited about the season
leading up to this point not even more
excited yeah I was too in fact I was
telling my guys I said I really like the
Bears to make that jump because it feels
like they got weapons yeah but it's
really Mitchell true Biscay it is you
know unfortunately for them they run the
ball really well Jordan how is a good
running back I don't think he gets
enough credit for what he does come with
three cones a good play you know just
things up they got some receivers they
got is it uh Robinson or Hertz from when
did we get
I don't hurt hurt Robinson from
Jacksonville Anthony Miller second round
yeah right yeah yeah Robinson yeah Allen
yeah okay yeah other I said me
basketball Nate Robinson
yes it's Nate Burleson anyway and then
you got Kevin why who's healthy Trey
Burton Gabriel from Atlanta you got some
weapons with are on offense some and
Negi running that offense no I think
they can do some things that did their
Kansas City as well why were you always
the spokesperson for the Bears and Jay
Cutler when you weren't even playing
anymore
I don't understand go to guy whenever
something would happen something go
wrong and then they go hey I don't know
why I'm always that guy I every when I
played I always said the right things
publicly I still say the right things
now I never Jane Jane ever said anything
we either who cares you know I was like
people feel like he owes people an
explanation I guess but he doesn't you
know he is who he is that's just the
that's just him how talented was she I
was talking about you that earlier was
you he's talent wise I put him into the
category with Aaron Rodgers physically
running around lies arm strength it's
just the decision-making process wasn't
quite as fast as Aaron makes decisions
with the football but nobody is no move
they go yeah so yeah but athletically
and an arm strength wise Jay's out there
with all of them
the quarterback though that you you love
that chess game with did you ever have
that where you go like Zach Thomas in
Peyton Manning you know it was you know
because twice a year and you know we
knew he knew we're gonna be in covered
to every plate and there's one game
around 47 47 snaps no second half in 46
were cover to everyone the game you know
it's just what we did but you know they
wouldn't do they knew what they're doing
he would see our defense he sneak over
to be checked to a run we checked to
cover one he checked to eat checked back
to a pass it's just it went back and
forth until there was like five seconds
on the play clock and then wellshe's
snarky at the line of scrimmage it
worked oh so he's he comes up they're
coming here they do the leg
motion like that in the middle of movie
you're like oh we gotta keep their
defense and it's like aw crap now we're
out of we're out of position and then he
checks to the play that the defense
we're in and then they usually get the
right play cuz they'll this time we're
here you got it you gotta be set when I
do that you know cuz if you're not
you're not gonna be ready but he's he's
gotten really good at it and with the
hard counts and stuff he never said
anything across the line of scrimmage to
Danny like to me no no we talked between
plays never and she's coming up line of
scrimmage no no nothing like that but
there we had some words on defense like
for our checks because he knew our
checks you know he play them twice a
year they would we'd have some words for
our stunts on defense then we have to
change every week because of him and
their offensive line so there are some
funny words we use throughout the course
of our games I like one I can't fly
can't say I'm on your show well we're
not curse words but they're words that
they shouldn't fly say on TV or radio
sorry can you mouth it words that start
with a P yeah you know pirate pirate was
our big check so we get words that start
with a P for our pirate check my first
time we check you know check and it's
like the linemen were laughs and he was
a big Sopranos fan and you know he knew
the character and big moaning where is
defense headed in the NFL I mean people
want to see points scored that's all
there is to it it's a it's an officer
driven game I don't know like you said
it's just it's hard to play defense I
can't speak from experience I don't play
anymore
but yeah it's tough watching these games
when the defense can't do anything right
you know they get penalized for
everything holding and all these calls
by the referees are debatable you know
it's all judgment call holding on
offense holding on defense all defensive
holding is pretty obvious but the in the
line of scrimmage man I just
I wish they'd have cleaned up the cup
blocks I don't know if they ever will
you know with cutting on because our
knees are important to as defensive
players you know we like to keep our
knees one guy what would you say if an
offensive lineman oh I used to go out it
with Matt Burke all the time the Center
for the fight and now I think he's the
head of the NFLPA or something I don't
know wait he's got a pretty good job now
I guess from what I hear we'd cut Blanca
he would get outside the pocket like he
was a good athlete so he'd be pulling
and they run screens and drawers and
he'd be and he cut me I'm big what I
didn't say like this I was like why are
you cutting me you're 300 pounds I'm 250
block me you know stay up high and block
me and not those words but there was a
lot of conversations he and I had about
him staying up high and blocking me but
that's that's your livelihood and we
don't care about the defensive players
knees but the offensive about their
heads we care about their chest or
shoulders everything else but we don't
worry about defensive players anymore
your kids playing football my son plays
your shirt tackle football play last
year didn't play a whole lot last year
didn't get really into the game but this
year he's he's starting both ways first
team mom's okay with this yeah football
it's a great game it's it's good I mean
he wants to play I'm not gonna say no
you can't play I said let me just tell
you one thing before you uh get going is
um they're gonna get hurt just a matter
of when and how bad so just know that
going in and he loves it and his buddies
play he plays with them and they have a
good time how tough is it to be the son
a Brian Urlacher well we live on Arizona
now which is nice so he's not the
expectations aren't as bad I think as
they would be in Chicago but he does get
some flak some time he's a little guy
right now he's just like me when I was
his age I was tiny as well I didn't grow
till later when I got a freshman
sophomore junior in high school and he's
hopefully gonna be the same way cuz I
was a little guy like he was now where
do you think you would have got how many
scholarship offers at one New Mexico's
only offer I got that's it so I took a
visit I I didn't offer some small
schools you know I didn't get there we
have Eastern New Mexico this is 90 miles
from where I grew up they didn't recruit
me a Texas Tech want me to walk on and
then a coach Fran I took a visit to New
Mexico and he was like we want to offer
your scholarship if you don't take it
now we're good to somebody else I'll
take it
sign me up and then after I got back
home to Lovington I can actually do my
school state college so they wanted to
come down and take a bit I said party
come here to you
returning punts in high school I was
okay now I did in college as well and
kickoffs that shows you how bad we were
how much speed we didn't have what are
you doing with a fan duel it's called a
gridiron pick'em so you go you put all
you have to is pick the winners every
week in the game are you any good at
this
well I am I'm okay so my wife plays
fantasy and she asked me for advice I'm
just not good but picking winners I can
pick anything she does the fantasy stuff
and she asked me for advice and I feel
like I give her good advice but doesn't
turn out being good in the end the guy
that sort of draft or play just don't
turn out the way well here's the problem
you never get credit if you're right
you only get blamed when you told me to
take it yeah well I also told you think
so so and they did great last week well
they were supposed to
that was actually my trash bag okay
can't win do you think would you ever
place a bet on a game now that it's
legalized um I've looked at some little
spreads on games yeah yeah did you know
the spreads when you play no heck no I
didn't you didn't care didn't care did
didn't matter well in effect the way I
played but motivation like you go they
got us as a two-touchdown underdog again
that wasn't motivation for me to try and
beat some limey if you needed the spread
to try and get you a hyper to play or
get you ready play then you're playing
for the wrong reasons did you ever have
a good pregame speech me yeah that give
one yeah no never I yeah I did actually
this the game the Hall of Fame game I
gave a speech to the Bears this year
first time they asked me to come speak
just to talk to the guys real quick
it wasn't pregame speech just like two
half hours for the game but to come on
there and just say what's up to the guys
and that was it
wait so why would you what you wouldn't
be good at I'm not I'm not a good a hype
man I mean if you need a pregame speech
to get you ready to player to get you in
the right frame of mind to play then
you're playing the wrong sport you know
if you need someone's motivation to get
you over that hump to play I don't feel
like you're you're doing the right
things do you think you could have done
what Ray Lewis did know his dance I
wouldn't have wanted over there
if I practice it maybe I could do it
yeah that Brady's a really good though
his dance move you might have pulled a
groin no doing it
why would I pull a groin he didn't he's
a little more athletic it felt he had a
better dance moves so you think he was
more athletic than I was or dancing wise
he answered mines so you said more
athletic though at letting as a dancer
okay I can go with that
no Nate Burleson said you couldn't dance
I don't want to dance okay but you have
to dance if you're gonna do ray Lewis's
dance well if I practice that and are
you more athletic than Ray Lewis
I don't know well wait you were just
arguing well you said he was more
athletic like it was not even close
raisin where I think than you that's
what basically what you said right he's
more athletic as a dancer but you didn't
say it first
how do you say this Ray's a great
athlete I feel like I'm a pretty guys
Lee - I think you're a better athlete
than Ray I don't know but dancing but
dancing wise I don't think you're you
could do Ray Lewis just squirrel dance
not as good as he does no chance okay
that's it but that's not what you said
do you want to hit me no I don't
definitely not do you have one last hit
in you because during the course or
break one of my I think Paul he wants to
take it a shot from you this is my last
one I'm retiring after this - okay but
you said that before
was it no we're gonna Brian Urlacher in
studio yeah but clay Mathews hit you and
then you won't want it across you he's a
pet you give me a little stabbed in the
chest I'm like you did that that but
only the punch yes in a solar plex I've
hurt my wrist yes okay this wrist that a
rough man football's rough but when you
wake up in the morning you're okay I
feel pretty good to you like over
mountain bike riding every day I'm okay
a lot of it okay right cuz Ray Lewis
does more than that when he wakes up
[Laughter]
what was Ray the whole thing now as well
yeah actually I gave my speech versus if
you want to go by that
yeah but alphabetically ray went in
before you true doesn't matter we're in
the same class what's your favorite
doesn't matter anymore that's what we
were told is your number 318 I think
Ray's 313 or 3:00 p.m. so he's ahead of
me again
got it Brian Urlacher he's gonna pop
somebody during the commercial break
joining us on behalf of FanDuel is there
a website is there anything damn calm
okay
why are you all fired up got me all
feisty okay call me a bad athlete Ray
Lewis joins us next
no he's great yeah wouldn't you like to
know he's not joining us Oh what do you
like the only not would you like to hit
him no he looks like a solid race six
one to fitty what are you six for 250
okay oh yeah I'm lanky see the problem
is I'm long um like Nate was saying I'm
my length is sometime works against me
but it helps me a lot of works against
me - yeah read the bottom laughs you are
this feisty the Bears go to one more
game Wow what it was where did I say
that I thought FanDuel dot-com Ryan good
to see you we're back after this yeah
let's go again what's fun for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]